welcome uh i'm julian i'm the author of
uh
this book protects in action uh and
today in this
twitch session so i'm very happy to have
you all here um
first off can you so i'm looking at the
at the chat actually
so in so this session is not going to be
like
um a talk in a conference is going to be
more like
live coding and showing you some vertex
some reactive
uh and also be monitoring the chat to
see if you have questions
and by the end of the hour i'd like to
have some kind of freeform q a so
please if you have any questions just
drop drop a comment i will have a look
and i will
i will uh try to answer you so it's a
bit unusual not to have
people face to face or hearing your
feedback but
i'll do my best um so
what we are going to do today is um is
pretty similar to what you can find in
the book although it's not exactly
the the same thing um so what we will go
through today uh
it's actually four things so the first
thing
we're gonna use is the we're gonna have
a look at the vertex core apis
especially what you call verticals and
the even bus
and we and we will be do building a very
simple http api
uh second thing we're going to do is
look at
some sql client or postgresql
then we'll do um we'll do some kind of
edge service
so we will play with a http client to
make requests to other services
and here we'll do some chaos engineering
which is extremely fun because you can
just break
everything and see what happens so
basically what we'll do we'll just
kill we'll we'll just introduce some
delays uh
in the sequel database and we'll see
what happens and how to mitigate
um to mitigate issues and if time
permits would look into
we look into real-time web applications
um so let me just show you
what we are going to do in the first
step um so what you are going to
we're going to use a very simple running
example uh
through the arrow um so what we will
have is
temperature sensors so they are not
going to be real sensors
of course because i don't have sensors
with here
um but you could just the code would
would not be very different from what
you would have if you had some real
sensor
uh talking over i don't know mqtt http
uh kafka mqp whatever so the idea
is to have this simple sensors um
so each of them is going to be a micro
service it's going to expose
an http interface a very simple api we
will be able
to to to to get their data from
and whenever they they update the
temperature they will
push an event to what we call the even
bus and we
we will see what happens uh in a second
step
would have another micro service which
is here
which is going to look for all
temperature updates and store this into
a postgres database and it will also
expose
some query some queries over some
http api the
third step we're going to have some
gateway slash edge service which is
going to give us
a simple api to get all the latest data
or some very specific data so it's going
to
look for updates and maybe sometimes
query
the store services and the last step
will have some kind of dashboard uh
which is a web application and it will
be
it will receive live events from uh
from from the whole system so we'll have
a live interface and i will show you how
to do it nicely with uh with vertex
so if if it sounds good um
let's start with this which is making
senses
um so i'm going to to use intellij but
you can just whatever you want to
really you can use visual studio code is
where
whatever you want so if we want to have
um a sensor we need to send a class to
represent
what's in the sensor so in vertex uh in
the core apis you have two concepts to
understand
one is the verticals and the other is
the avengers
so a vertical is where you will put your
code um
the whole business logic is going to be
in two verticals
and verticals is the basic deployment
and code unit you will have to deploy
it's as simple as that so if you wanna
have a sensor vertical well you have a
sensor vertical and um
what you have all you have to do to make
it a vertical is to extract
is to extend something called abstract
vertical which is
part of the core apis of vertex
so what we we will need to
to do a sensor um first thing we need
some kind of
identifier so the uuid is
really really fine uh so we just
generate that
uh we're going to have a temperature
which is a double
uh so this double is going to evolve
over time uh and we will see how to do
that
um and to make it change we have a
random
number generator as simple as that um
of course we need to log events because
it's very convenient to log and see what
happens
um and the last thing is we will need
some http port
to um to run the server so
to do that we will just use uh
environment variables
uh so in our case it's going to be http
port and by default
uh it's going to be on port 8080 but
it's something we can override if you
want to
so that's that's really the skeleton of
my
of my vertical um and the vertical is a
very simple thing
uh it doesn't it doesn't have many
methods basically what you need to
to override is the start method maybe
the stop method
in some cases if you want to do some
cleanup
uh work uh when you shut down the
vertical but
in practice it's really the start method
uh which you are going to to have to
override
stop yeah it happens but not that
frequently
so when you have this stop method when
the vertical is going to be uh
to be started um you can see
here we have an argument which is a
promise so
this is because we are using vertex and
in vertex everything is asynchronous
so we are going to deal with lots of
asynchronous things and because starting
the
vertical is going to be made out of
asynchronous operations
we need a promise which is an object we
will complete
to say whether we are
whether we actually succeeded in
deploying the vertical or if we failed
so what i mean by that is that we this
vertical is going to start an http
server and because you start an http
server
you need to report if you manage to
start the server
or if you failed and basically the
reason is
is very simple um you may not be able to
start a server for example if you start
below
if you if you if you use a port number
which is too low
basically you're going to fail because
you may not have the permission
or maybe the port you want to open is
already in use
so in those in those cases you will fail
so how does that how does it work um
so let's start by um just updating the
temperature
so when you're in a vertical you have an
object which is called vertex
which is a field and from here you have
lots of
basic operations so for example i can
create an http server
um i can access the even bus which is
something we'll have a look
a bit later we can deploy particles
um we can have periodic operations
we can close the vertex context we can
have data ground circuits uh at server
class client we can make the dns
client because we may want to make
queries you may have a http client
we have a tcp client etc etc
so basically you have all these um
low-level
methods to create all kind of networked
applications with vertex
so if you want to um to update the
temperature what we need to do is to
have a method
a callback which is going to be called
say every two seconds so every 2000
milliseconds
we're going to do something like this
update temperature
okay so this is going to be called every
two seconds and from here we're going to
update the temperature by some random
number um
so the long parameter which is given
here is just the
identifier of the uh of the of the
property timer
um in my case i just don't care but
you know you may be interested if you
want to cancel this
periodic timer basically so
what i'm going to do here is um
i'm going to say temperature
equals temperature plus um
i'm going to use next question for my
random number generator and i'm going to
divide to divide that by
two that's it so next question is going
to give me a number between minus one
and plus one and i'm going to divide by
two so this is going to be a very simple
model to update
uh the temperature um
so i'm going to do this and i'm going to
log
this to say um
temperature
updated
and i'm going to give the new value and
i'm going to do
temperature like this so if i
if i want to run this so i'm not even
creating an http server or anything
so i have my periodic task which is
being set up and i want to um
to say that my vertical uh
is working i'm just going to say
complete on the uh on the promise to say
okay i'm done my setup is done my
vertical should be working so
here we go
so we will come back to adding an http
server and http api but first
let's try to deploy this vertical and
make it work
so in vertex you don't need anything
like uh you know you don't need um an
application server or you don't need
this
this kind of thing you can just have a
main method
and it's a very simple programming model
you have a main method you deploy your
vertical that's it
so what i'm going to do here is create
a vertex object like this
in this vertex object i'm going to say i
want to deploy
a vertical so you can pass
a name you can pass an instance you can
pass a class you can pass many things
something you can do is um so what's the
name again it's sensor vertical you can
save sensor article new
like this and this is going to pass
a supplier and
what's wrong with this
so i've made a mistake and i don't know
why
so i'm going to do something very simple
new sensor vertical
okay i'm just going to deploy it like
this
and run
so uh yeah and this is it
so you can see that every two seconds
you know my temperature is being updated
and so i'm going to start the
application and show you
show you one thing from the logs um you
can see here that
uh the the thread identifier in logs is
going
to be the same or for every invocation
so this is called the event loop thread
zero uh
if i had deployed another instance it
would be
another another thread so basically what
i can do is um
i can show you what happens if i deploy
this multiple times
so it's sensor vertical
and you can pass deployment options to
say i want
say four instances like this so if you
do that you will
you will deploy four instances of this
vertical
and what's going to be different here is
that
you see that i'm stopping it again
you can see that we have different
different threads because we have four
instances we have
four threads operating so one thing you
need to know is that
a vertical is deployed to exactly one
thread
which is an event loop which is
processing asynchronous events
and it's something you should not be
blocking you should not do some blocking
operations
while you're running uh on the event
loop
so that's a very simple um
example uh i'm going back to um
[Music]
with this and have an http api
um so what we need here uh now is
so we need to create an http server um
so there is a nice router object you can
use
uh so a router is a is an object to
define
uh your http endpoints uh based on path
and methods etc so you can define a
router like this
um you can say that when you get
a request on a http get request on
slash data then you want
you define the handler so the handler is
going to be called
to process the http request
um so we can call this getdata for
example
uh we're going to create this method
with
context more to that in a minute
and yeah i think i think that's it for
for this method
so what we need to do now is create the
uh
http server so we create each
server we say that all requests are
going to be handled by the router which
is then going to dispatch
the request to handlers uh
we say that we want to listen on board
um
you know the http port which is given as
an environment variable
and this is this gives us a future
so it's not a this future object is to
notify us whether the
operation which is here starting the
http server succeeded or
whether it failed so
do not confuse the vertex future with
those from the jdk they are much more
complete in vortex and they are
non-blocking which is not the case of
those from from the gdk
so first thing is we're gonna say so in
case of success
so when we manage to start the http
server we're gonna say
so we have a callback here uh on failure
because you know you you have some kind
of failure while we say
stop promise fail so by doing this you
will just propagate the failure down
um to the um to the class
that's been deploying um
so we are going to say http server
running so
we are going to repeat the
some stuff in the logs like the uh http
port
okay and once we have that we can do
start promise dot complete to say that
the operation succeeded and
we need to actually implement that so
when git data is called uh we need to
uh to answer the the http request and
give
basically the temperature data that we
have
so what you what we have to do is
prepare
some kind of json object
which we call payload or just call it
whatever whatever is fine to you
uh in this object we are going to so
this is a json object is from vertex
it's a class we have
so we here we are going to say um
we so the id i'm just checking something
what's been expected from the other side
yeah it's uuid not id
so uuid we just put our uid
these are current methods so you can
just change things
um temperature um
we pass the temperature and we put
the last thing we put a timestamp
because it's very important and we just
use
system current time milliseconds it's
not too bad
and then we go through the context now
so we say context.response
um so we we need to say that
it's going to be json so we say uh
common type
so we had um we need to add this header
to say this is application json content
and yeah basically we just need to end
it with the string
um so we would take our payload
and we say encode so there are two
endcon methods
to encode json to text so any code is
the
comp it's the compact form which is a as
a one and string
um but sometimes when you want to debug
there is also encode pretty which is
going to give you a nicely formatted
json object
so we just encode um something we can
also
we're going to set the status to 200 to
say uh
the request was fine uh we may also log
to the um that we've been processing our
requests
processing http
query or request
from and we are going to give the um
the requester so we go contact.request
remote address and this is going to tell
us who's been
making the request so
if i do this and i run my application
if i run this should work
so let me check so my temperature is
being updated
great my server is running etc so
everything is happening on one thread
again
um so i'm using port ht808080 sorry
now and it's data
and it works so i'm making a query and
i'm getting my json
object it's very simple
and if you look into
the logs what you can
what we can see here is that again there
is only one thread
that's been managing the periodic task
to update
the temperature and also so the http
request
so the threading model in vertex is very
simple
once you deploy your vertical is running
on just one thread
it's going it's going to be an even
thread and it's going to be the same for
the whole life
of the vertical
yeah by the way if you have any
questions just drop something in the
comments
and i'll do my best to respond
so that's how you can do a very simple
microservice
something which has been specified um
because the next step will be to have a
store like this
or this way uh so we have a store so
we we want some some service to be able
to to notif
to be to receive all the updates uh so
this means that
my sensor service needs to publish
the temperature updates to something
called the even bus
so let me show you how to do this
so i'm going to go back here um and in
my
um edit temperature method i'm going to
publish this so i'm going to reuse this
actually
um creating the
http while the json um
payload so i'm going to have a method
called create payload
like this
and i'm going to go through the event
bus so
i go through the even bus and i say
publish
to some destination which is a very
simple string so i'm going to say it's
temperature
that updates um i publish
some json which is my which is my update
and this is going to be sent over the
air vendors
so when you do this
i can show you how it works um so for
example
um i'm going to my main method i'm going
to do something you would not do in
practice but
i'm still going to do it just to show
you what how it works
um so the even bus is really um
what you should be using to make your
verticals communicate
uh with from fmr1 events
um so you can have a consumer that's
going to listen to
temperature that updates
and it's going to receive a message
and that message um it has uh
it has an address a body and headers
which you can define so it's a very
simple lightweight uh
kind of not messaging but eventing
system
um and whenever there's an update what
you can do is
log from here so it's going to be logged
from the main method
and i'm going to do something not really
nice but
like this and message the body
and i'm going to
just need to say it's json object
because it's going to be some json so
and n code 3d so
in the logs it should be nice
and this way so my vertical
and my main method they should be
communicating like this
so as you can see um from the main
method
i'm using another event loop so the
vertical is
is on a one event loop and the main
method
is creating some kind of hidden context
under the hood for you
just to stay faithful to the
vertex threading semantics but you
you receive this update over the event
bus
so that's one part of the equation um
the thing is the event bus like this
it's working just
inside your process it's not working uh
across the the network and it's
exactly what we need to achieve in this
step
so in this step we need the evan bush to
work across
the machine so there is a mode called
the uh
clustered event bus so we can have a
vertex instance but
working as a cluster and
in this case the the even bus is not
just working
inside your process to dispatch events
but it's also working across
a distributed system with as many nodes
as you want
well as many depends um of course you
have
three i mean 30k
instances of our network i'm not sure it
works fine but
yeah you get the idea um
so if you want to use the clustered band
bus
the only thing you have to change is
here
it's here so when you you want to deploy
so
you do you say i want the vertex
clustered vertex
with some options so in these options uh
there's a whole bunch of thing you can
customize but
for today you don't need to customize
anything
and basically so yeah the
clustered vertex instance is not going
to start straight away it needs to
connect to the cluster and set up the
cluster manager etc
so it's an asynchronous operation and
again we can use the future
to to say um we have
our vertex instance on success
and on fader uh yeah
we have a failure we can't connect to
anything
so in this case we may just log and say
error
because oops so i'm not trying to be too
creative in the
in the names as you can see and here
we're going to deploy
a vertical and we deploy um
sensor with sensor vertical
and that should be fine so
if i run this like this it's going to
run with clustering so with clustering
you have a bunch of
cluster managers by default we recommend
hazard cast because it's it's fine there
is infinite span as well
with j groups you can use console with a
model from community you can use apache
ignite so we have a g we have different
engines
that you can use but the idea uh so i'm
going to
shut this down and switch to the uh
terminal to show you how it works
so i'm just going to um package my uh
just just try to to come combine to have
some jars
and run stuff because i'm going to run
four sensors on the command line um
so i have something called run sensor on
port
the 8080 like this
so when you start you have a bunch of
logs from mostly hazelcast
and here it's telling you that there is
only one node
in the cluster right now uh but if i
start another on port 80
81 so it's going to start another chord
but
in the logs we should see that the yeah
so we see that in the in the cluster
when i have two members
here uh and if i
create a node like this like this like
this so
if i run 82 and ig
three we have four
sensors running and they are dispatching
their
temperature updates to whoever wants to
listen on the uh
on the even bus that's not so it's not
too bad
um i'm going just to do something in
advance
to show you um how it works
i'm going to run the dashboard just to
show you that we have live updates
and then later on i will show you how it
works so it's
http
i think it's in port 5000
yeah so we have here our four
our four sensors uh and we have the live
updates
so it's all running with the dashboard
in real time
so yeah the point here is just to show
you that just by changing
just by putting vertex in custom mode i
have um
i have all my notes sending events to
whoever is interested
so i'm going to shut this down because
the goal was not to show you this
straight away
and we're going to switch to um
the next step so having postgres
uh a service to um
to store events so it's going to listen
to all these updates and store that into
a database
so how it works um i'm going to switch
to
so we can just forget this project we go
to temperature store
and it's using a postgres
reactive client from the vertex project
so it's a clean
implementation based on the wire
protocol of possible sql
so it's not jdbc it's really
non-blocking
code that we give from the vertex
project
and the performance is is really really
good
so to connect here to connect there so
it's
more like the same canvas for the
vertical
we are going to run on for hd port
7k and when we want to connect to
postgres uh we are going to use the
class called pg pro
so pg pool is the pool of connections to
our database
um you need to pass some options
like obviously what's the host of the
database
your credentials the database cetera
so in my case it's all um hardcoded in
the
it's in the code and i'm not showing you
the good thing sorry
yeah this way
still new to this obs thing so um
[Music]
you create this this pgpool object um
and then you have so your host user
database
credentials etc so here this is all
hard coded which is bad
of course um
so yeah this is bad but of course it's
something you can override with
variables um file configurations files
etc so
i'm just putting this hard code in
in the in this example because it's just
very easy to understand
so what you need to do is um so to
receive the updates
you just listen over the avendus to
temperature updates
and whenever you get an update you will
just call
this method which is going to make an
insert into the database
then i have some http api because i want
to
either fetch all the database or i want
to get to fetch
only the data for a given sensor
or i just want all data but over the
last five minutes
so these are the different words um
i have defined for this service um
and yeah to show you we are going to do
uh this
implementation so get all data so
get all data um first i need to show you
the um
the schema so i'm not using any um
object relational mapping tool or
anything
it's just plain sql and possible sql
so the schema is pretty simple we have
the uid
uh the timestamp the value of the
of the template temperature update and
the primary key is a combination of
uuid and timestamp it's pretty
straightforward
sql so if we get there
so the query we need to do is select
everything from temperature records
um so we need to to go with pg pool
uh have a query appropriate query so we
need
like this and then we need to execute
so you can pass a tuple uh a tuple is
one if you want to pass values
i'll show you that you know something in
another query
uh so i'm going to execute and when i
execute
uh again it's an asynchronous operation
because you need to talk to the database
fetch the results and
get back to you i'll get back to you
so we have a future and i'm going to say
on success so i have a
row set which is a bunch of rows
so in this case i'm going to do
something and on fader
i'm going to uh
fader i'm going to do something else
so i will start with the failure
so i want to get all data i want to just
so if i have a failure i need to
basically say everything everything's
gone wrong
so you go through the context um you
just fail it
like this say 500. so this is http 500
to say
boom i'm just dead um and of course
what you should be doing um on the cert
on
on the server side you should be logging
so say whoops
so i don't have time to be fancy with
the log message
um and i just wrap up the failure
so what's more interesting is what
happens when we actually
have the the rows um so we can do
something like
uh for um row row
in rows and we're going to do something
so what we need to do is assemble all
the um
[Music]
all the values into some kind of json
biggest knob
json document so for that we can have a
json array
like this so it's a json array
for each row what we need to do is array
that happened
to add so we add a new json object
and this json object is going to be made
out of these values
from the row so we need to say uh
uid comma
uh what am i doing put
so we put u like this your id
so raw dot get value
uh get it's a string so you can say get
string
uh u e like this
um we need to repeat
so i don't remember the schema it's the
value okay
so we need to put temperature
um in a row that get
double
value yeah value
and we need to repeat the
[Music]
what am i doing
and we need to repeat the uh
yeah like this
something wrong uh pom pom pom pout
timestamp like this and it's going to be
get temporal i think
and it's t stump
so at this time i'm going to go to
string because otherwise
it's not going to work um
let me check because i i'm lost with
all the parents and stuff okay
so i'm adding every row to the array and
then
yeah then i should be fine so i can just
go to context
um the response
so we need to say that this is a
json
let's put header so we say conon type um
it's gonna be json
and we end with uh so we create a new
json object
just to wrap the array into an object
which is a quite common pattern if you
if you do some json
um so we say data um
and we press array and we encode
and we should be good yeah
so uh does it work
so let's try so again it's vertex code
is very simple to run you can just use
the main method
and run run from your ide you just
you're just fine
uh we're just waiting a few seconds to
see in the logs that
we've joined the cluster so yeah
connection reviews of course because i
didn't start the
i didn't start the postgres server so
yeah so to start the server i'm using
docker compose
it's very simple i don't have to
remember the whole
darker command line thing which is
big to say not to say anything else
and i'm going to start again my service
so if you join the cluster
you should see all the members which are
the sensors plus
this new service
okay so this is deployed and you can see
in the logs that
we are record we are recording a few
values
that's fine um and then if i make a
query so it should be
http i don't remember the
the port so what's the default the
default port for my service it should be
7k okay so 7k
and i don't remember
it's all okay very simple
yeah and tana
you get all the data from the from
database
so again this is running uh from a
single event loop
for the vertical and that's pretty fine
um
there are some other uh things you can
do like
for uuid so if you want to have a viable
path
a variable in your path uh you can do it
this way
with um this syntax
so it works pretty pretty
it's pretty similar so you do another
kind of sql query
uh and here you can see that you have a
parameter which is
here dollar one so it's going to be the
uuid of the
sensor you'd like to get all the data
from
uh to pass this as an argument you wrap
it with execute inside the tuple
and there and there you go and then it's
pretty much the the same logic you have
if you want to get the last five minutes
again it's on the vertex side exactly
the same logic
you make your query and then you you had
the http response um
then it's just you know get back to
school do sql
pretty simple
and the thing i should be showing you
which i haven't is
what happens when we receive an event um
so we just do
same thing here we just do an insert
into the database
and we just store the data we receive
from the even bus
in json and restore that onto the even
bus
does that make sense for you do you have
any question
not seeing any questions yeah oh yeah
yeah um
somebody said in the chat get back to
school or buy a book yeah i cannot i can
remember
recommend you this book it's not too bad
so
um what we can do then we do some chaos
engineering but before that i will show
you um
edge service also how to use an http
client
uh so the goal here um so we have our
sensors
oops there no not
yeah this way so we have our sensors
we have um the store service
and now we need some kind of gateway
slash edge service to
make a simple http api to connect to all
these uh
all all these things um before go ahead
so there is a question where the tuple
class comes from
uh the tuple class is from the vertex
sql client
so it's simply something we have in the
vertex apis for the sql clients
so it's not stoppable from some of the
libraries
uh another question can you use a no an
object relational mapper
um it's not
well in theory you could um
i would recommend if you really really
need something which is not
plain sql i would recommend you use
something called juke
and there is a binding on the vertex
juke in the community that
you can find other than that
it's actually refreshingly simple to do
sql believe me or not it's actually very
simple
um so if i go back to coding
so yeah when i said maybe you don't need
an object relational mapper it's
it's not intuitive but yeah
sometimes simple is better so we have
our edge service
um so the edge service is that gateway
style of service
so i'm going to rush
through this thing because
i'm being very talkative today so i'm
going to
try to yeah
going to try to go back to um
was the no not this one okay so we
so we need to do it um very quickly so
what's different here is that we have
something called the web client so the
web client is a nice
usable http client if you want to make
queries to other services
um and the idea in that
kind of gateway service services that if
you do slash latest
you will just push back push back the
the latest temperatures you've been
observing
and you've been observing and caching
them in a very simple hash map
and hashmap works again because there is
no uh
race condition concurrency thing going
on so you just
you can just use because you're always
going to access it from the same thread
you don't you don't need to do anything
you don't need to synchronize log user
locks etc
so if we want to get the last five
minutes
from the gateway we need to talk to the
store service
so what you need to do here is use the
web client
and do a get so you can do you know get
deleted
post whatever http method you want
uh so you need to talk to the uh
i have an environment variable for that
store host okay
so store bought store host
and i don't remember was the
url url
um so in this service it's
last five minutes so you need to make
this query to the
uh all the service so that's five
minutes
so what's nice with uh this um
[Music]
this api is that you can say that you
want the response
to be decoded for you like as a buffer
just an array
text whatever so you can just say
just an object
so you say give me just an object
because it's much
nice nicer for me um
what else you just send them you just
send
and you have you have a
you have a future so it's going to give
us an http response
so i'm going to do something like map
to say um request
request that body because it's json
i just want to map so that i can extract
it
and i have my json which is great
so when i have my json cool on fader i'm
going to
simply say failure
and context failed 500.
um so again i should be logging etc
we don't have much time so i would just
do something a bit
a bit simpler so i have my json which is
from the other service so i need to
choose my context
uh go through the response
just say again that this is going to be
some json
and end with json of the encode and
should be okay and status 200
although you have it by default it's a
bit better to do it
it should work um so i'm just going to
quickly recompile so i have my
postgres database running compilation
should work hope so yeah
so if i go to the edge service i'm going
to
um
run the edge service so it should be
yeah whoops
should work so i hope it works
like this um
[Music]
just waiting for it to start so it's a
bit longer to start because
we are using clustered even bus if you
don't use clustering
it just starts in a snap with vertex
um so if i do this query
um and i want so what's the
end point it's latest okay so let's see
latest
so this is the latest there are from the
event bus and the other one
is five minutes
so if i do five dash minutes
i have an error cool um
this is the the beauty of doing things
on the go like this um
[Music]
well they did go wrong
so for some reason there is a failure
and there is no good demo without a
failure
don't don't don't so i've made something
stupid i'm sure
and of course i'm not reading anything
so i can't find it
so let me go back to the edge main
method
should be this one okay so
i need to expand this
and log
okay so i'm going to kill the version
which is running here
i'm going to run from here
so maybe i'm just wrong with the port
numbers or something
okay so this is starting blah blah blah
6k
so can i see anything whoops
and connection refused okay so i mean i
think i'm not on the
correct
of course so it's not running
so yeah so i must run the store
and port what is it
6k
i know it's 7k i'm on
7k sorry for that people yeah
wrong endpoint yeah you're right
so this works
uh the edge
here should be working and then
yes it works so i'm making a
some so yeah i've been able to do to do
this
yeah yeah it's so good so i have this
working
um i'm just going to launch it from the
not from my id but from the the command
line because
now we are going to do some chaos
engineering which is great
um
so don't cry here we are going to break
everything
so just running the edge service so i
have my
four sensors my store and my edge
service
they are running i'm just going to check
if
i can get yeah so everything is running
and i'm going to use a tool called hey
um and i'm going to um do this query
like last five
[Music]
five minutes
is it is it the good one actually five
minutes like this
yeah so i'm going to say and hey it's a
very simple tool to do some um
some load testing um so by default it's
doing 200 requests
and we have this distribution of
response times so
it's basically the latency so it's the
time when you are talking to
the edge service and the edge service
talks to the
store service and the store service
talks to the database
so of course you need to warm up
the application etc but you know it's
working
so i can see in the chat that somebody
is waiting for
proper chaos so you can see that all my
responses
are pretty okay we are below um
yeah we are yeah we're pretty good
um so what i'm going to use is a tool
called
pumbaa um
and and i'm actually not going to kill
the database i'm just going to introduce
some delays
over the network of the database to the
service
it's pretty simple so all the network
requests that go
through to the postgres
to the postgres database they are going
to be delayed
by so for one minute they're going to be
delayed
by three seconds plus minus
five uh well open five seconds
so i'm going to do this um p
decals like this and we got some delays
so
my database is still working but now if
i make a query
so i'm going to do it manually like this
and we just got to wait for
you know some time so hp 3
plus i don't know seconds
so we're waiting we've got some delays
and everything is down
and if you if you run hey like this it's
going to be worse because it's going to
be
nightmare of delay so
with vertex we've been using
asynchronous things it's been great it's
been fast etc
but all of a sudden everything is going
down
because we have delays
so basically my system here is not
responsive it just
you know stuck because of network delays
um so yeah i'm going to to let a run
in the background um
but what we need to do now is to
mitigate the
this kind of failure so if you want to
mitigate this um
because i don't have much time i'm going
to use
some git magic and get back to uh
the version that was working properly
um so just yeah
just to show you what they had so just
by introducing network delays uh we had
this kind of histogram so
yeah the the response time is going it's
going to the roof
um and it's not been too bad here
because
we were near the end of the uh chaos
period but
yeah it should be it should be worse
than that if we've been running hey
differently it would be much much worse
so um if you want to avoid that and have
a service which is still responding even
if you have a failure on the database
side or any other service
site you need you need to use something
called the circuit breaker
so a circuit breaker is a very simple
kind of proxy between
you and something else uh once you when
you want to do an asynchronous operation
and when when you start to see
enough pages so you have a threshold
that you can set
once you start to see failures the
circuit breaker is going to be
open is going to be open to say it's not
it's not worth
sending requests because the assistant
appears to be down
so it's got the circuit breaker is going
to be open and we can just respond with
some default values and after some time
the circuit breaker is going to be help
open so it's going to try to reconnect
and if the next request succeeds we get
back to the closed state so
the circuit breaker says it's okay you
can you can make your request
and if it fails well you just go back to
uh to
to being open to make sure you're not
trying to overload the system which is
broken anyway
so it works like this um so you have
your
circuit breaker you give it a name as
simple as that
and then when you want to make the web
client query like this
so you so this is more or less
what we did manually
and we are we are doing two things so
one thing is i'm adding a timeout
on the http queries to say that after
five seconds if i don't have a response
it should be an error this is a good
practice to
to to do because if you want to ensure
bonded time on your responses you need
to sort of you need to send a bond
so just give a timeout uh something like
maybe 10 seconds 15 seconds depend
depends on your system don't do
something like 500 milliseconds because
it's probably too short but do something
like this and then
you wrap the whole operation
with the circuit breaker with execute is
giving you a promise to say
when you've completed the operation
correctly or not so when we get the
response
in our case um when we have a success we
um we complete with adjacent value
so we pass so the promise is going to
complete with
the json value if we manage to to make
the request
if we have a failure we just report wrap
up the failure to the
circuit breaker and then so this is the
future
and when you one then you have your
future so
on success so you've managed to make the
request
um so what you do is that you cache
the cache the result it's going to be
used
later on so here you just get back to
the client with a response
if you have a failure then
the good thing is that you're going to
fail so there are two options
either you just fail but you fail
quickly so your client is not stuck
waiting for some response which is going
to happen in maybe
a minute or two minutes or i don't know
so you just want to fail fast
uh and then it depends on the
application domain but
if you know you're managing temperatures
like like we do here
uh we don't really care about what
happens with
uh we can just serve some old data so we
just cache it
so if we have some older data we will
solve the older data
and if not well we just failed but at
least in both cases
the service is still able to respond so
the difference
here so i still have
my database i'm going to
introduce some chaos here
uh i'm going to kill
the old version of the edge service and
run it again
so i have some chaos going on i have my
edge service
and i'm going to make a request so i'm
going to request the five minutes
and yeah it's not what i wanted
i wanted to make yeah it's been fast
but it's not it's not exactly what i
wanted so i want to show you what
happens
not with lost testing but you know i'm
just doing a request so
in this case well i have nothing
i can give you because there is an error
um and because we use the
the circuit breaker then the circuit
breaker is waiting so we're going to
wait
yeah for the circuit breaker to be half
open so it's ready it's ready to try
again
if we try again it's going to wait five
seconds
until we get a timeout it's going to
break again
um so the issue here is that we have no
cached
data um
so here the chaos is done so
if i do this at some point it should be
open again
open circuit and then i have a question
in the chat
yeah uh
what's going on it's half of them okay
yeah and there and there i get some
values back so it was the time for the
circuit breaker to be um half open and
ready to make
something again so if i run the chaos
again
and i tried to make that regress again
uh proof it yeah it's going to wait
it's going to have some issues but it's
going to give me some cash data
so i'm going to be quite uh
it's going to be quite okay and if you
use hey like this
the the the histogram of response time
is not going to be too too bad
uh there is a question in the chat
what's the maximum number of elements in
a cluster
of well there is no strong limit
so it's a bit hard to say but if you
tell me you have 50
instances i'm probably going to tell you
is fine then if you tell me you have
3 000 k is probably too much
you know what happens is that that the
more not you have
the more traffic you have on the network
uh because you need
depending on the cluster manager the
more is chatty then you have
the even bus communication so yeah don't
go crazy
but for a reasonable number of
instances it should be fine so yeah you
see that
you know just by using a circuit breaker
you're able to keep your service
more or less responsive so that's
more or less what i wanted to show you
um the real time
dashboard i'm going to show it back to
you
just so we finish on that and then some
questions
so again this is a dashboard uh is going
to be connected to um
to vertex and listening to all the
updates uh
from the from the sensors and it's going
to be updated
in real time um here
i can show you how it works so it's
actually using the even bus
just like we did for for the other
communications
so how it works is very simple so you go
to the dashboard
in the dashboard java class we have
it's serving the
the html page
from the as a static file and then there
is this
special thing called the uh so gs
handler
so sub gs it's more or less like
web circuits except that it's a library
that can degrade to other
type of connections like long pulling
if you have a browser that doesn't
support web web sockets or if you are
on a network with some proxy that
is disabling web socket connection etc
um
soc.js is able to you know have some
kind of degraded mode to uh to handle
this
um and yeah the idea with the stock.js
android is that it's going to um
allow the javascript client
in in the browser and the back end to
communicate over the oven bus so it's
actually extending
the eventbus to um to the um
to the client like this so the dashboard
service
is listening to all the temperature
updates and pushing that to all the
you know connected browsers um so
how you do that is so that's on the
backend you just need to say
which destinations are being permitted
because you may not want to forward all
the events from the oven bus to the
javascript client and then you have the
same programming model
uh on the back and in the front
so there is a small library uh which is
called
vertex web socket something
i forgot
with yeah vertex even bus yeah
productive members so you use this and
then you just connect to the even bus
from javascript so you have the same
model
and you basically register your handler
for some kind of destination over the
even bus and just like you would do in
your java code
on the server side uh you receive
messages
and when you receive messages uh you can
just here update the uh
the the interface uh something you need
to know is that
with this even the subject so it's not
just the back end which is pushing
evidence to you on the front end
uh you can actually publish something um
i'm not trying to get the competition
correct
but you can say yeah you just send
you can also send some events some
destination
and you can pass some some json if you
want to so
it's really handy because you can have
the front and the back using the same
model of using the even bus to pass me
to pass events around and have some
communication so that's
really how it works um
we are a few minutes passed with the
arrow that was
given to us but manning said we had time
so
i guess we can uh we can have a few
questions
um so if you have a few questions please
drop them in in the chat
and they're on a stupid question so
just ask me anything so there is one
person which is late uh don't worry
you're going to be able to to get it
um question is would you mind to repeat
what vertex is
uh and actually didn't say what vortex
is so vertex is a library
for writing asynchronous and reactive
services
applications in java so it's a very
simple toolkit you can use you can do
all kinds of
networked applications and it's reactive
meaning that
it you can scale it so you can scale
multiple instances
to adapt to um to some traffic
and to deal with failure as well and
it's reactive because
you have some bolts and nuts if you want
to um to handle cases or you have
failure so you want to
um just like we did with chaos
engineering which is something you can
you can catch that in in the replay uh
when you have a service you make a
request to that service the service is
down
uh there are ways to not be stuck
waiting for some response which is not
going to uh to uh
to happen so yeah your activities it's
not just
about being asynchronous and scalable
it's also about being able to
deal with failures and managing the
response time to keep it under control
no matter if you have a system that's
working well or if you have failures
any other question folks
so there was a question about how much
penetration is it having
in the market is it being used for
projects in production of course yeah we
have
um so i can't necessarily give names but
if you go to the vertex
website you will see you will see
examples
so vertex is being used for many kind of
services
uh it's been used in the game industry
for back-ends
for games it's used in
lots of enterprises system as a gateway
as a microservice
development framework slash library
it's used in internet of things
to aggregate data from various sources
um the the there is one example
which you can find for on the michelab
log iit for example
uh they are using protects for connected
tires to
collect data um and integrate it with
all kind of other systems they have
so yeah vertex is really general purpose
to make distributed systems that are
reactive
so yeah just just to close on that there
are lots of users
and at red hat we use it for so we have
vertex as a project but we also use it
as the foundation as well not the
foundation but
one of the foundation for caucus which
is our
other enterprise framework uh is this
non-blocking io
event loop model yes absolutely um
if you're familiar with node.js there is
a small difference
so with node.js when you start an
instance you have one event loop for the
whole program by default
so you can have workers etc but it's not
really the same thing
in the case of um vertex by default you
have multiple event troops
based on the number of um cores you have
on your machine
so yeah all the asynchronous operations
happen on event loops
somebody's saying i would mention that
vertex is polyglot yes
so the big focus of course is java but
you can use
kotlin you can use jruby you can use
groovy if you want to you can use color
and the good thing is is that in all
these languages
um we have some idiomatic binding to
these languages for example if you use a
scanner you will use not vertex futures
but you will use
uh the scalar future so you can use
pattern matching
all this stuff uh if you use scotland we
have a great integration with
the the corotins of kathleen uh if you
use groovy you have
you know bindings to have some nice dsls
for groovy et cetera et cetera so yeah
uh
i didn't mention it but the and the
focus is mostly on java
especially in the book but you can use
vertex with multiple programming
languages on the jvm
i think we have time for just one last
question
who's got a question in the chat
and by the way uh there is a code down
group here so there is a promo code
um it's minus 40 for mining
uh so mining tournament was a permanent
code um
and i'm not sure but i think it doesn't
just apply on the book
so if you're interested in some other
book at manning you can use it for
to get 30 off some other book
so somebody's asking um
[Music]
400 450 micro microservices is that a
good
number and they are using hazelcast uh
four
yeah so your below 500 instances using
azure cast
yeah i would say it depends what you do
i mean i can give you a definite answer
um but if it works for you yeah it's not
a number which is shocking
i'm not shocked by 450
instances so it should be fine i guess
then if all if you already chat you over
the even bus and you're just
publishing tons of messages to everybody
then
yeah you get some natural traffic but
it shouldn't be too too hard for on a
mod
on modern system it's not not too big
so yeah i would say it's good probably
if not then just blame me
all right so i think it's the end of
this session i'd like to thank you
all for coming here it's my actually my
first twitch
so yeah it's a fun format
uh if you enjoyed it just let me know uh
you can contact me on twitter
uh i'm at j porch so just
send me something just tell me if you
liked it uh if you have any feedback any
comments
uh if you want another twitch session on
something more specific
just let me know and i will see with
many or i will do it on my own channel
but if it's related to vertex
i can schedule something with mining so
yeah
thanks everybody goodbye and we're going
to stop the stream
thank you